foreign
foreign
foreign
all right
we are
amazing welcome to to the uh fall estate
YouTube live I'm Jesse Lee Peterson
apologize for the late straw but we are
black and black people are late
we start our CP tank I'm glad you're
here you love me I don't really know you
do you have to know me to love me yeah
well I love you thank you are you
surprised not really were you surprised
that I threw you off the radio show
not really and one of the reasons I'm
concerned about you being a progressive
is that me specifically are all
progressives all men men only men only
men Progressive women don't concern it's
normal normal abnormal for women to be
Progressive interesting oh a liberal but
it's abnormal for a man to be a liberal
or Progressive it's a sign of being a
beta male I didn't know we call real men
are conservative if I became
conservative would I no longer be beta
you become Alpha well
something to think about do you find
that it's difficult for young men mainly
your age group to find good women to
date not at all right why don't you date
men I'm not attracted to men oh good
what would you considered it might be a
man would you think of it as a man it
would I think of it as a man right it's
a person right I don't say yeah it's a
female the children are rely on the
liberal media the Democratic party the
writer Republicans the never trumpers
okay uh so like everybody but Trump
mentally off you know like like the life
was on but nobody was home you're making
assessments of who's mentally off on TV
but that's how evil the children of the
left are they'll destroy you to get what
they want and that's power and well I'm
curious if they're so powerful the
children of the life they're not
powerful oh that's what they want I
think they will destroy you they will
they'll destroy you they'll try to
destroy you oh okay to get power do you
agree with that no no we're bringing
that up the reason was you've called me
a girly man so many times remember that
we talked about the week oh okay that's
because it's not because I think you
that I'm gay right
got it glad we clarified you know a lot
of people are sexually assaulted and
raped and they don't come forward and
the reason
you don't believe that that's a made-up
line too oh who made that up the
children are the left oh I should and
Children of the life yeah they're doing
it because they hate men and they
especially hate straight white
conservative Christiana made of power if
it wasn't for them America would be a
socialist society already it would be
what a socialist society by getting rid
of jobs many people mostly took care of
people about getting rid of full-time
jobs and they had to work two part-time
jobs in order to survive so you don't
even understand the talking points free
Obama phones
that's the answer but I don't like the
answer you don't understand the question
I think I understand it uh what what is
it about the question that's difficult
for you do you would you David Pac-Man
believe it just because she said it I
liked how you had to check what my last
name was there
I would leave it enough to investigate
it yeah
give me just a yes sir I'm black and
slow so give me a simple yes or no your
friends are watching right now I hope so
and they're watching because they
thought you're gonna keep my butt so you
got to live up to it I found out this
was a debate today would you believe it
are these really the most important
topics for you absolutely okay are there
others that are more important for you
yeah our economic system wealth
inequality Health Care geopolitics
nuclear disarmament climate change and
the black people go into a trance
and they go in and they just yeah they
they reach for the D while eating
chicken I guarantee you if they went now
and voted for and asked them to vote for
it they'll go with the homosexuals I
hope so and the Democratic party they
have been morally bankrupt well I just
radical homosexuals have got in there
and corrupted churches and so anything
else not that I can think of that's it
yeah amazing people coming from [ __ ]
countries and we don't have no idea who
crossing the borders uh we could have
Bin Laden folks coming I think we just
disagree amazing
um
it's crazy to disagree isn't it is that
a good thing that the president has done
what did he do worry about jobs how it
doesn't matter how he's brought them
back is that a good thing if you're
going to claim he did it you have to
explain how is that a good thing that it
happened before there are two new jobs
the question is what did he do to bring
the jobs
can you identify what he did I just told
you man how do you know he did it and
it's a good thing that he did or not
jobs are good I'm asking you what Trump
did you saying yesterday what is a man
I'm sorry what is a man
I do politics not dictionary are you a
man love What is love
I I don't do dictionary definitions I
won't be doing dictionary definitions at
any of my events that's the one thing if
people are expecting that I'm not doing
any dictionary definitions
they're so amazing it's incredible you
like celebs I'm sorry life less I don't
know any have you ever slept with a [ __ ]
I don't think so would you date a [ __ ]
it's a pejorative it's not a term I use
amazing did you have fun no in in a
thousand years when the sociologists and
the philosophers try to figure out what
exactly happened in the United States
right around this time this type of
conversation is going to be incredibly
informative for them so I'm glad to have
participated in it good man they're
going to think wow Jesse was amazing
check out our brand new saw on the uh
destinypeterson.com on my Instagram
oh you're doing songs now huh
Facebook Twitter you sing are you
playing Instagram
you know what a beta male is
no check out the song cheers Trump right
Alpha not beta see him with the toilet
paper on his shoe super Alpha move huh I
didn't see it but
Apple
thank you all thank you Dave thank you
all right
mangoes my bag of mangoes
I love mangoes too nonsense okay
under our body's regime my bag of
mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
bag of mangoes mango art mangoes like
three boxes
eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
[Music]
all right that got messed up I
accidentally hit a button so I guess
we're cutting the song early that's my
fault folks I very much apologize we are
going to be talking about the global
panic over the omnicron I know it as
Omicron but some people say I have other
names for it it's called The omnicron
exactly
um I don't believe as yet the Panic is
warranted but we will get to that we'll
also talk about the extension of masking
in the United States it has been
extended I also will wear for the first
time a proper niosh certified n95 I've
never worn one before but I will be
flying tomorrow I don't even really
understand how you put it on uh but I'm
gonna try it for you guys in a little
bit
um and this may be the last stream of
the Year quite frankly because I fly out
tomorrow and I'm gonna be gone for a
while now I may do some streaming while
I'm gone
um oh hold on a second we already have
to be bad it's actually crazy it's it's
people are already getting banned it's
humiliating
um
this may be the last stream of the year
but if we get to a hundred I'll do more
streaming okay I'll I'll take breaks
from my vacation and do uh more
streaming I do want to say thank you to
some people who have already signed up
here and unfortunately I seem to have a
limitation on Twitch for how far back I
can see why is this let me see here if I
uncheck this
man I I don't know why I can't go back
further
I know Jen here just gifted two deeper
shades of house resubbed Fifth Dimension
signed up Nikki 206 and I think there
were two more or no three more so
that'll put us at seven
also want to say thanks to Gabor Casimir
who just signed up at joinpakman.com
putting us at eight okay so that's where
we are right now
um from that particular standpoint all
right so they are doing the Christmas
tree lighting like I don't care about it
and we didn't you know yesterday while
we were streaming they happened to be
doing the menorah lighting for the
fourth night of chanukkah and today
they're doing the Christmas tree we'll
be here streaming so we'll look at it
but it's really not the point of today's
stream let's talk about what's going on
with uh Omicron first of all U.S Titans
travel testing requirements mask
mandates as part of a broader fight
against covid
the Biden Administration tightening
travel rules and within the U.S
requiring all inbound International
passengers to test within 24 hours of
departure I genuinely don't know how
that's going to work I really don't
um and many of you know the
circumstances I had traveling back from
Spain uh three and a half months ago
where my girlfriend had two false
positive antigen tests and we needed it
were it not for getting a PCR which took
24 hours we would have been stuck in
Spain there would have been no show in
the second half of August I would have
been quarantining in Spain and um
if there had been a 24-hour requirement
at the time rather than 72 we would have
been screwed
so that's a problem I don't know how
it's going to be managed also extending
mask requirement on all domestic flights
and public transit through March 18th it
was previously February 18th at this
point it's hard to imagine mask mandates
for Air airlines going away anytime soon
anytime soon
uh the changes are part of a broader
plan another article about this as well
let's see what we have here the steps
come as the first known U.S case of the
Omicron variant was detected in
California in someone who came back from
South Africa a week ago there are also
cases now in Minnesota and hold on do I
have it second U.S case in Minnesota
someone who had been in New York guys
it's everywhere already it's it's
everywhere at this point
um the governor says there's no
confirmed cases in New York like
obviously there are so I mean not
confirmed but obviously there are cases
also Omicron found in Colorado we still
do not know if it's more severe we just
don't know if it's not more severe then
this could be the beginning of what
Vincent rack and yellow said is likely
to come eventually which is more
transmissible less severe
um which is what we want doesn't mean we
go out and we try to get sick right
that's not that's not what it is at all
uh but that remains to be seen we we
just do not know
um further tightening testing
requirements we know that only a 24-hour
window to be tested that's that's really
really tough really tough particularly
with PCR
um
I don't even know that that really I
mean I
I don't know I go back and forth about
the travel measures
particularly the travel bans for certain
countries where it's like by the time
they ban South Africa from traveling
here it was already in Europe it was it
was already here almost certainly
um
Joe Biden pulling out all the stops will
encourage vaccinations make them
accessible launch family vaccination
clinics and on and on and on so
meanwhile in Germany Merkel to enforce
lockdown for unvaccinated with coveted
surging not too dissimilar from what's
happening in Austria
um
oh hold on we gotta ban someone
spreading disinformation the covet
survival rate is not
99.999998 about 0.8 percent is the death
rate of covid and that is six times that
of flu so we have you're just going to
get banned for the disinformation
there's just no there's just no
tolerance for it why even bother
really sad the number of people getting
banned I want to say thanks to
chronically Steph for the twitch Prime
sub very much appreciate that stuff
Germany is poised to clamp down on
people who aren't vaccinated and
drastically curtail social context to
ease pressure on increasingly stretched
hospitals in one of her final acts as
Chancellor Angela Merkel will hold talks
with the 16 Regional premieres later
today which are expected to agree on new
curbs including only allowing vaccinated
people to or recovered individuals into
restaurants
theaters and non-essential stores
according to a draft agreement prepared
by merkel's office there will also be
tighter contact restrictions for
non-vaxxed people nightclubs will be
closed in places with high rates and
there will be strict limits on
spectators at large public events
the more than 12 million adults not
inoculated is what is creating a
challenge for the health system
um
if you look at vaccination rates very
pleased to see Spain and Portugal
extremely high extremely extremely high
vaccination rate you love to see it
um
some problematic elements over here now
what you have to also remember is some
of these countries do not yet have
ubiquitous access to vaccines
um a factor that we certainly have to
account for
so that's what Germany's doing let's
look at what Austria is doing
um
here it is
Austria introduces lockdown for
unvaccinated about 2 million people who
have not been fully vaccinated have been
placed in lockdown we are not taking
this lightly but unfortunately it is
necessary so listen a lot of people have
been asking me David sir
what is your view as to what people
should be doing and I am not a medical
professional so I wouldn't I'm not going
to suggest to people anything that I
come up with okay I'm only who am I I'm
no one I am just gonna go by what is
being said by medical professionals
right please proceed Governor exactly so
my view is that there's essentially two
approaches at this point in time these
are I'm not telling anybody Which choice
to make but I'm saying there are
essentially two approaches at this point
one approach is
any level of elevated risk is not
tolerable
and thus you essentially need to hide
out
right I mean it's like you you if you
you just gotta be a Hermit that's one
option
the second choice is to say
this is going to be the situation at
least for a couple of years right I mean
when you look at the numbers that are
present okay
we had the April Peak then the July Peak
then these subsequent Peaks November
December January and then we were back
down we had a pop in April again and
back down we had a big surge at the end
of September and then back down and now
we're all the way back up okay it is
extremely unlikely particularly with so
many anti-vaxxers in the United States
that this is just gonna go away you know
people talk about the end of the
pandemic
um the end of the pandemic will be it
slowly becomes endemic and hopefully
less severe so it's up to you to decide
your level of risk
right now
the way I'm thinking about it is
I've had my third dose I'm very
powerfully boosted
um my Wi-Fi is off the charts on the on
that basis that's a joke by the way I
don't want to get demonetized
um
I've had my third shot
I am avoiding certain things like for
example I was 95 done with big concerts
before covid it's just annoying last I
told I went to a Billy Joel concert I've
got some guy drunk
elbowing me the whole time cheering
every time he likes this I just don't
need it I'll just watch the concert on
TV
large sporting events
okay you know I've been to I've been to
the football I've been to the hockey
I've been to a hundred Celtics game how
I don't really find the need to do it
I'm annoyed by the crowds I'm done I'm
probably done with sporting events and
large concerts for the foreseeable
future Outdoors when I travel up to the
Berkshires in Massachusetts and go to
Tanglewood and see Yo-Yo Ma at an
outdoor venue of course
of course but
um
so I'm not doing that now the last five
percent is because of coven I'm just not
interested
indoor restaurants I'm back to indoor
dining now
uh uh you gotta you wear the mask when
you go up to order and then you take it
off or whatever
I don't care about that I'm choosing
restaurants based on is it packed and
the tables are stuffed together or is
there some clearance where you're you're
basically just sitting with the people
that you're with I'm not going to the
really crowded indoor restaurants I'll
sit outside or to the restaurants I go
inside I want some separation at the
tables I'm comfortable with that you
wear your mask to order or whatever just
to be brought to your table and then you
sit down that's I've accepted that level
of risk because I I think it's
acceptably low
um I already don't go to church or
synagogue or whatever I'm continuing not
to go am I traveling yes after the Spain
false positive incident and in addition
now with a 24-hour testing requirement I
don't know that I'm doing any
international travel for the foreseeable
future tomorrow I'm going out to the
West Coast yes
um I'm gonna wear my mask everything
it's warm I'm going to be mostly outside
it's an acceptable level of risk for me
um
everybody has to figure out for
themselves but it's not really going to
be too different for the next couple of
years it seems pretty clear
uh and so these are the options and it's
up to everybody to decide what to do I
had one other thought on this I'm trying
to what was the other component of this
um
in terms of
in terms of indoor events with friends
if it's more than a few people
everything I've done everybody's taking
a test on the way in and of course there
are questions as to the accuracy of the
tests and all those different things but
uh
it's been an additional kind of kind of
layer I guess I would say
um so listen people's people have got to
figure out what works uh what works for
themselves right
go on the Hassan Pike or stream what
does that even mean
like watch History
what's he even doing
he's not live
yeah he's not oh my God I got like some
frog in my throat
he has guests okay yeah if he wants to
have me on that's great I'm gonna be
showing up at Hassan's house next week
actually it's going to be quite a scene
it's going to be nuts actually I can't
even imagine I want to say thanks to
Jeff builds a base for uh supporting us
via twitch Prime I very very much
appreciate that super chat's coming in
don't you dare to give us a cold turkey
this may be the last stream for the Year
guys I'm not I'm not gonna lie
Daniel says Irma gerd it's the Irma Kern
Vernier oh my God
that that is pretty weaponized
uh
uh geez let's let's move away from that
okay so we took care of this we did
omnicron the omnicron it's called the
omnicron right
uh we did this
oh okay yeah fourth fourth doses are now
being talked about Jersey's most
vulnerable to be offered a fourth covet
jab
um Jersey's most vulnerable people will
be offered a fourth vaccine officials
say anyone with a problem with their
immune system will be contacted this is
a plan for boosters from Friday those
over 40 can get appointments for a
fourth dose as long as they had their
last at least three months ago if you're
under 40 you gotta wait until January
booster dose interval for all Islanders
aged 40 and over will be reduced from
six months to three months
what does Islander mean oh this is
Jersey oh my God what I'm an idiot it's
BBC this is the island of Jersey I'm
like it's kind of weird to refer to New
Jersey just as Jersey but they're
referring to Jersey Island oh my God I
feel very stupid all of a sudden
okay so anyway this is what they're
doing on Jersey Island and
um
it's quite likely that fourth doses at
some point will be coming to the United
States uh I already anecdotally know
people
looking very strongly at getting one
soon all right so we gotten that out of
the way here's something really really
funny Donald Trump Jr just tweeted
bragging Trump already sold 100
000 copies of his book 50 times more
than Chris Christie's book I guess Chris
Christie in its first week only sold
like 2500 copies it's like of course
it's a picture book look at who's buying
it it's a picture book
it it makes perfect sense that based on
the educational uh uh uh interests
um of trump supporters that they would
buy a picture book at a much higher rate
I mean Pablo themselves there's no
question about it
not a big I'm not I don't know that I'd
be bragging about it necessarily uh okay
do you guys want to look next at the
Nigel farage Trump interview I did Clips
on my podcast but we can look at some of
the full interview or do you want to do
The Joe Rogan dangerous conspiracies
it's no longer about you know the moon
landing we'll do both we'll do both but
tell me what you want to do first in the
meantime thanks to the freak and full
metal Crusade twitch subscribers uh now
numbers 11 and 12 today please sign up
at joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code obamna to get a big discount Obama
scotus hearing on abortion long and wide
segment on that on today's bonus show
okay check that out on the bonus show
and yes guys super chats are on you
could there's just you can see the
little edge of it the green Edge the
first two are just up there
the super chats are on okay
um
it's not clear whether people prefer the
Rogan thing or the Trump thing
hmm
all right we'll start with the Rogan
thing let's look at this
so um this is like really really really
really really really bad
um
this is the latest from from Rogan this
was during an interview with Jocko
willink and here's Rogan's new theory
about monoclonal antibodies and the
vaccine okay and here's the thing I'm
gonna say this because it's [ __ ] true
because I've experienced it many many
and I'm going to keep track of each
claim and then we'll go through each
claim one by one any people that I'm
friends with they're withholding
monoclonal antibodies they're trying to
stop people from getting them there's
not a [ __ ] shortage of monoclonal
answers what does that do monoclonal
antibodies kills covid like raid kills
roaches when you get shot after you get
you get covered then you get this that's
what they gave Trump and that's what
they gave me I got I got better quick I
got better [ __ ] quit and Trump got
better pretty quick pretty quick and
he's old and fast he's always fat and he
got better in four days so why are they
withholding it because they want you to
get vaccinated that's what I think I
think they don't want there to be a very
clear path where you don't have to be
vaccinated but if you get sick you're
going to be fine so so or is it just the
money going into the pharmaceutical
companies that's driving people to want
everyone to get back or must have an
influence it's also the narrative
there's also people that have been
vaccinated that don't want people to get
away without being vaccinated why
because I think they know they took a
chance I think secretly they know like
if anybody pays any attention they know
someone who's had a bad reaction to the
vaccine all right so let's go through
each of these claims because this is
this is really a Gish Gallop this is
very very dangerous because this guy has
such a big audience and again
I have no idea if Joe Rogan people ask
me am I beefing with him now are we on
bad terms I've been on Rogan's show
twice I have no idea if he's aware of my
coverage of his vaccine stuff I wouldn't
hide any of it I would gladly talk about
any of it with him on his show every
time I mention it people are like David
he'll never have you back on you loser
it's like I understand that he may not
because he might not like the things
I've said he also might have no idea
about the things I've said so go through
the claims one by one the first claim is
that there's no shortage of monoclonal
antibodies and and so we have to really
kind of get to what it is that he means
by that
and what I think he means is that the
monoclonal antibodies are just as
available as the vaccines now that's not
true it's just not true the monoclonal
antibody you can read about the
production process it is much more
difficult to make doses of monoclonal
antibodies as nearly as quickly as it is
to make vaccine doses so it's not true
the first question about there's a fake
shortage of monoclonal antibodies you
don't have to call it a shortage but
there's not widespread availability in
the way that there is for vaccines read
about how they're manufactured okay I
don't want to I don't
I have a firm grasp of every step in the
process but you can read about that
that's number one number two
he says it knocks it out it kills covid
like raid kills roaches and they gave it
to Trump and Trump got better like that
neither of those things is true it is
true that in double-blind randomized
controlled trials the antibodies are
efficacious relative to a placebo which
is why they received emergency use
authorization just like the vaccines did
right if you trust the monoclonals but
not the vaccine they both initially were
approved on the same emergency basis on
the same on the basis of the same types
of Trials that's number one number two
Trump was very very sick remember they
lied about how sick Trump was and Trump
immediately got the monoclonal
antibodies and he still got worse and we
subsequently learned even though Dr Sean
Conley was very very kind of skeevy
about it that Trump was on oxygen uh
they were part of the rush to get Trump
to the hospital was we want to do it
while you can walk because if you get
more sick which we're worried you will
we're gonna have to bring you out on a
stretcher so so it's also not true that
with trump it cured it like that okay
third claim
kind of the fourth where where Jocko
says
why do would they rather is it because
of money for big Pharma and Rogan says
it must be
think about that the vaccines are made
by big Pharma at for profit
and the monoclonal antibodies are made
by big Pharma for profit
so even if you say when there's a
plausible thing I will buy into it this
isn't even plausible because both are
very profitable and by the way one
treatment of monoclonal antibodies is
far more profitable than one vaccine
dose or even a full course of vaccines
which is now you know two to three doses
so it doesn't even it doesn't even pass
the sniff test the vaccines also are
much cheaper
at the societal level even though you
give it to everybody rather than only
people get to who get sick that's how
much cheaper the vaccines are relative
to the monoclonal antibody so the profit
motive is trash
um and then what was the other one oh
everyone oh that was so so crazy
people who got vaccinated
want others to also get vaccinated
so that they also expose themselves to
the risks the gamble of getting
vaccinated
what are you talking about and then he
also says everybody knows someone who's
had a really bad reaction from the
vaccine I have personally spoken in my
life to if you include people who call
in
a thousand people who have been
vaccinated right I mean people I know
and people
nobody nobody mentioned anything more
than just flu-like symptoms
so
five different false points this is very
very dangerous stuff it's very very
dangerous stuff at this point in time
um and I think people seem to agree with
me mostly in the chat
um
oh thanks to dirty kurda and black white
Rook for the twitch Prime subscriptions
numbers 13 and 14. also thank you to
John canelis John just signed up on my
website joinpakman.com with the coupon
code felony21 you can use the coupon
code Obama
you can also use the coupon code
felony21 both are completely legal
completely legal
all right everybody other super chats
coming in David can you check out the
GOP War Room YouTube channel look at
their chicken tender video maybe in a
bit why do you think Rogan panders to
conservatives and Boomers more lately I
uh it's it seems to me that um Rogan has
gotten sucked in in Texas I guess he now
hangs out with Greg Abbott that lunatic
Texas governor we know he hangs out with
um Alex Jones he's hanging out with Tim
Poole I just think he's in an
environment where
um he's getting this stuff constantly
and it sort of just sounds sounds
reasonable to him
do you think him saying he's a comedian
saying you shouldn't take his views as a
cop-out it's not a cop-out but I don't
know
thanks for not groveling at Rogan's feet
like everyone else yeah I mean listen I
get this is one of those things where
like I recognize that me being on
Rogan's show it brings me attention and
brings me audience and that's fine
um but
I'm not gonna pretend like uh
I'm not gonna just ignore the things
he's saying he's saying things that are
definitely dangerous at this point and
I'm gonna I'm gonna cover it Evan says
I've been taking monoclonal antibodies
for 15 years for autoimmune disease they
cost thousands of dollars and have
severe side effects they only help in
covet if you're undergoing the cytokine
storm uh okay I'm not sure about that
that may be I'm not saying you're wrong
I just don't know enough about that to
say but you you may be completely right
about that
um okay
will I give out any free stuff today
sure
um let's do I'll give out a free item
from my online store to number 20 today
how about that
20th person to sign up on my website
we're at 15 you go to joinpakman.com you
sign up I'll give you a free item from
the online store all right let's go next
to okay I had a few other things here oh
yeah let's actually let's do that but so
I'm gonna play there's been a crazy
situation on a plane where flight
attendants kick off a guy for freaking
out I guess about wearing his mask so
um I am going to be wearing an n95
tomorrow on my flight I've never uh worn
one of these before I do have a stack of
them
um and
I'm just gonna see what the Comfort
level is why not I mean I have them it
seems I might as well wear it uh let's
see how comfortable it is hold on a
second how do I even put this on
do both of these straps go over my head
is this it is it protective in this way
no okay hold on
this is not going well
wait
oh my God this is insane
what it it's like what the hell
it's like it's not supposed to be down
or on my neck is it
this is extremely uncomfortable I'm not
gonna lie
hold on does this go higher
there's no way I'm wearing this on the
flight it's seeming like
do both it's like where does this second
strap go
that doesn't look right
it's also there's holes right here
seems terrible
wait it's upside down
oh this is a chin strap hold on a second
now I lost my earpiece the hell is going
on
well I guess there's nothing I have to
hear right now
the writing no no no this is a nose
thing right here
this is a nose thing
fold the metal oh I need to fold the
metal okay hold on let's try it again
oh I see oh that's way more comfortable
now
oh now we're talking
hold on what about the second strap
okay that's actually not terrible I mean
I look completely insane but
you know I might just wear a kn95 I'm
actually thinking this is this is pretty
uncomfortable
it's like unless I keep this off of my
ears I don't think I'll make it
maybe just like this
this seems good
hold on
is this allowed to just have the strap
over my hair I think I think this is the
way I would have to wear it if I'm going
to survive a six hour flight
um
maybe duct tape
yeah
yeah I've got like a hundred kn's maybe
I'll do that
man that is that is horrifying all right
let me get strapped back in that might
be the worst n95 I've ever seen no it's
the only one I've ever worn
the straps are really bad okay
man that is something that that is not
comfortable it'll probably keep people
away from me because I'll look so insane
that's not a bad idea all right
um I want to say thanks to Papa boat
for the twitch Prime so I very much
appreciate that am I going on the hippie
dippy show with Dylan Burns he uh did he
say something about that because
yesterday he sent me a message asking me
if I'd go on is that a coincidence has
has Dylan Burns mentioned that I may be
on because I did tell him it's always
Fridays and I just don't really do any
work on Friday Saturday Sunday
um
so I told him maybe January 7th
would be the the next time I might be
able to do it
because
um tomorrow I'm flying and the next
Friday I'm away and then the Friday
after that I'm away and the one after
that I'm flying back and the one after
that is New Year's Eve and then so we're
looking at January 7th
all right thank you very much thank you
very much everybody I want to say thanks
to Alex Richmond for signing up on my
website with the coupon code Obama new
member number 17. also thanks to KT cow
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code Obama oh and that is new
member number 18 today thank you very
much I do appreciate that in a serious
manner
will you cover the Dr Campbell video on
Ivermectin Maybe
just want to say how much we appreciate
your lives thank you
did you see breaking Point's coverage of
Andrew Yang your Andrew Yang interview
yeah we played it yesterday speaking of
tenders had chicken tenders the other
night found one shaped like a boot crazy
stuff uploaded two videos on my Tick
Tock okay yeah we're not looking at
you know the shapes as interesting as
the shapes of chicken tenders are I
don't know that we're going to look at
that
right now
um
I think you nailed the issue Rogan's not
a bad guy but hanging out with the Phil
Hillbillies going full Boomer mode
okay let's look at this incident this is
I hope I don't experience this tomorrow
on my flight
there's a guy up here I guess with no
mask that's that's the context
from the uniforms it looks like a Jet
Blue flight
four [ __ ] hours
[Music]
so what I'm guessing happened is after a
big flight delay the guy wasn't wearing
his mask and he was asked to put it back
on and then he still wasn't wearing it
and then he was told he has to leave
that's my instinct here
the second he said something I pulled it
over my nose
[ __ ] [ __ ] no give me my [ __ ] give
me my [ __ ] give it to me
[Music]
oh my God
okay this can't be good for employment
status
like it's hard to imagine this is the
biggest problem in the lives of these
people like if you're behaving like this
on a plane my guess is you have other
issues also you're contending with but
maybe I'm wrong
I
hi
um
why is her mask not even on now
like it's very clear they're Justified
and she even now she's still not wearing
her mask
s
[Music]
this is really embarrassing it's really
really embarrassing
is this woman also drunk it's hard to
tell but this is super cringy
um
[Music]
what did she say if she's Bacardi
of course of course everyone you know is
what it's already
popcorn anyone
and what a humiliation I mean just a
complete and total humiliation there uh
so that's that
[Music]
um
okay let me see what else we had here oh
yeah a few a few faucy things oh this is
about Omicron from earlier today Dr
fauci did make a few statements let's
take a listen here's what we know right
now the individual was a traveler who
returned from South Africa on November
the 22nd and tested positive on November
the 29th
the individual is self-quarantining and
all close contacts have been contacted
in all close contacts thus far have
tested negative
the individual was fully vaccinated and
experienced mild symptoms which are
improving at this point
so this is the first confirmed case of
covid-19
caused by the Omicron variant detected
in the United States
and as all of you know of course we've
been discussing this this we knew that
it was just a matter of time
before the first case of Omicron would
be detected in the United States all
right
um a couple other clips about this I do
want to say thanks to Cosmo's blueberry
babe for gifting two subs and Lucan 860.
um that puts us at 22. also a big thank
you to Monkey play chess who just signed
up at joinpakman.com with the coupon
code Obama Obama okay here is another
now this is interesting this is about
travel bans let's listen
to in in Mozambique what Justified what
justify imposing a travel ban on
countries that have zero case of the
omicon
you know that's a very good question an
important question and and we did
struggle with that but we wanted to see
if we could buy time temporarily so I do
hope that this gets sorted out and
lifted before it has any significant
impact on your country yeah I mean you
know so I I do question the the wisdom
of the you know it's like by the time
South Africa sequenced this and came
forward and said good sirs this is
happening we have this variant it was
already in uh Hong Kong it was in
Belgium it was in the Netherlands it was
almost certainly in the United States
although we didn't know that for a fact
but now we know a guy came back on
November 22nd and tested positive on the
29th the 20 yeah but so and you're kind
of punishing the country that said hey
guys we have we have we know about a
variant and it's already everywhere it's
caused chaos people getting to Southern
Africa people getting back from Southern
Africa I don't know I don't know uh I'm
just not sure it's it's everywhere
exactly people are saying it's all over
Europe it's worldwide it's in the UK
just not sure about the you know wisdom
of that
um here's one more
um question
to furthering it's it's spread by
lifting travel restrictions for example
so out compete the Delta variant you're
talking about something really dangerous
you're talking about let a lot of people
get infected to see if in fact you could
protect them that's something that I
think almost all infectious disease
people with any knowledge about
infectious disease would not say that's
a good idea right I mean it's like that
you wouldn't try to spread it trying to
spread it is crazy it's like chickenpox
parties the equivalent of a chickenpox
party
um but it would be reassuring if it was
less severe it would be reassuring if it
was less severe you can't control if
it's more virulent and less severe it's
going to spread you don't try to spread
it and you still protect that risk
people you still get vaccinated you
still do all those different things but
trying to infect people seems cuckoo for
Cocoa Puffs
um yeah Dennis Prager might be a guy who
tries to do that I get the feeling
people get busted pulling down their
masks for two seconds on plane have it
pulled down longer than two seconds on
purpose yeah when I last flew there were
people playing really fast and loose
with actively drinking where they they
go like this
while watching a movie
to have the mask down the whole time
and you know then they started with the
announcements of you have to be actively
eating and drinking and you should cover
even between sips and bites that's like
the next level
um yeah there was a woman who had a
two-hour drink because uh it was the
movie lasted two hours it was it was
pretty wild
um
yeah I got a straw exactly thanks for
streaming can you throw the unvaccinated
and Obama
my pleasure
okay as we wait for the um Christmas
tree lighting Let's uh yeah let's check
out the Nigel farage interview check
this out what a propaganda piece this
was
[Music]
it's an heroic appearance
[Music]
foreign
from the moment in 2015 when he
announced he was going to run to become
U.S president Donald Trump has been in
world news he's dominated worldview it's
already funny look at this facial
expression it is already absolute and
pure comedy every day for five years all
over the world it was it was Trump has
said this Donald Trump is alleged to
have said that and what other people
said about him yet something very odd
has happened since the beginning of this
year outside the United States he's
virtually disappeared has he been
silenced is it voluntary what is going
on no people are thrilled he's gone
that's what's going on well today we're
going to find out we're gonna break that
and the first big foreign interview with
Donald Trump has done this is Trump
speaks to the world with me Nigel farage
here on GB news good to see it well I
didn't know it was so quiet but if you
say so that's okay with me
what on Earth is that because of social
media to a very very large extent
I don't know I mean I have not heard
that but it's possibly so I have a lot
of things to say and sometimes I want to
say them and sometimes I don't feel it's
appropriate to say it based on the
position uh we had a great election we
ended up it was a rigged election
unfortunately we got more votes than any
sitting president in history by far 75
million votes more than 12 million it's
already out of control I know and if if
Nigel farage wanted to be taken
seriously he could ask for even a shred
of proof for any of these claims that we
had from the previous election which was
instead he's nodding Nigel farage is
nodding at the lies 63 million votes uh
I think we've uh we've said a lot about
a lot of things and certainly there's a
lot to talk about if you look at what's
going on and uh Afghanistan with the
withdrawal which was I think the most
embarrassing moment in the history of
our country and no not quite not quite I
think there's other competitors in the
game you look at our borders what's
happening with our borders you look at
the cost of energy we were energy
independent and you guys notice that
Trump does that you look at the our
border there's like the the sniffs are
interjected in a very particular unique
way we no longer are you look at so many
different things you and I could talk
all day yeah and it's a shame what's
happened to the United States
whenever Trump says it's a shame it's a
lie okay so when Trump tells a story
prophesied they they came to me and they
said sir it's almost certainly a lie
when Trump says and it's a shame it's
also a it's a tell that he's lying also
when he's speaking it's a tell that he's
lying it's through Twitter
um it was was for you you know something
that used a massive effect oh Jack
Dorsey is being removed as a CEO of
Twister because of shareholder pressure
but whether that means it's funny
because it's not even Trump who's doing
free association Nigel farage is jumping
back and forth between a completely
unrelated topics as well they'll improve
as a Channel or not when I was amazed
the day that the Taliban you mentioned
Afghanistan a moment ago the day that
Taliban took over Kabul I did put out a
message that said it seemed ridiculous
that their leadership was still active
on Twitter
and yet you were still bad well they
were wrong in what they did and were
dealing with the United States President
who's obviously a popular president from
based on everything that you see and and
them and Facebook and I think they made
a big mistake I think if they had it to
do over again they wouldn't be doing it
we are uh you know we get the voice out
we have to do it we have a an obligation
to do that but he's leaving I guess it
was probably enforced because they're
down and also there's no excitement on
Twitter anymore
not only conservative people are leaving
and being canceled so they're Trump left
Twitter that's interesting potential
they're leaving and in my case you know
we used to get tremendous interaction
with liberals and uh and everybody else
and now they just say it's a very boring
place to be Twitter it's going down the
numbers are going way down no they are
on the election as you said I like how
ferrets just buy it they're absolutely
going down are you talking about the
stock price number of users amount of
Engagement number of tweets uh I think
that the average American audience
farage sounds like he knows more because
he has a British accent but I think he
may be nearly as incompetent As Trump
you say you've got 11 million votes more
than you got in 2016. because we know
what happened you know 29th of February
last year I was with you backstage at
CPAC and and I thought he's going to win
40 States I mean things were looking
anyone who thought he was going to win
40 States is an idiot didn't um didn't
Tim Poole put out a video saying Trump
was going to win 49 states as if it was
a serious political analysis like listen
when I did my prediction of Hillary
versus Trump in 2016
I got like a couple States wrong and
that was the difference and people
excoriated me for years saying David
will you you should never comment again
because you got the election wrong
the people saying he was going to win 40
45 states that that's not even remotely
plausible
terrific the pandemic hit and then you
kind of got criticized from both sides
Biden said you were xenophobic because
you closed the borders you you said we
don't want foreign air travel we don't
want this virus being brought in the
other side said you didn't lock down
hard enough I mean difficult in a
pandemic to win as a president as a
leader but the real effect really
because a whole bunch of world leaders
were re-elected on the basis of their
handling of the pandemic so it's
obviously it's not it can't be that hard
to win of course was for the first time
ever in America tens of millions of
ballots
being sent out yep through the mail
system well they use covid or the China
virus as they call it uh to Rob and rig
and steal an election and they sent out
millions and millions of ballots nobody
knows where they went in so many cases
and everybody knows it you look at even
polls now a big percentage of our
country knows it and it's very yeah for
people wondering I believe this is the
relevant Tim in 2016. Nate let me see if
I can actually find it
hold on here and it's betting odds now I
know betting odds aren't a guarantee
it's just what people think but therein
lies the point if USC dornsiff is saying
wisdom of the crowd is a better
indicator ladies and gentlemen behold
from DraftKings election pool only one
state thinks Joe Biden will be president
in this tweet oh this is different
though
they say with over 350 000 entries a
majority of people in every state
besides Colorado predict Donald Trump
will be the winner
of tomorrow's election now predict it
doesn't say the same thing they think
the odds are favoring Joe Biden but why
then is it that predicted is giving I
actually don't think this is the one
where Tim Poole says he thinks Trump
might win 49 states uh okay let's get
away from that let's get back to that
that's not the clip
um let's continue here very bad for
democracy very very bad the problem was
in so many of these states because
they've never seen it before kind of
what they did in in collecting the votes
wasn't against the law and that was part
of the problem well but they didn't get
it approved in many cases by
legislatures now remember that's not
necessary we've talked about that many
times before it is not there's nothing
illegal about Secretary of State or or
um making decision that there's nothing
there's nothing illegal about that you
have to so therefore it is against the
law it's not it wasn't approved by state
legislatures you know you can't do it
even through a court you can't do it has
to go through the legislation that's not
true that's very much the legislatures
didn't approve this stuff and the courts
didn't have the courage to take it up
right and so it's an interesting
situation that is all a lie we'll see
how it all ends out I mean a lot of
Americans as you rightly say a lot of
Americans are genuinely concerned about
election integrity and I have to tell
you from my experience back in the UK
Mass postal voting you know leads to the
wrong results very often absolutely
automatically by the way it's a bad says
it's cheap it's about magic I mean they
put everybody on their millions of
people on the honor System
with that and you know they've done
studies on it everybody knows it every
study comes out you can't do it and it's
a shame you can't do it these mail-in
ballots are edges whether it's your
country whether it's the USA it's uh but
here's the open invitation to cheat but
here's the problem
I've seen some pretty extensive private
polling that suggests that up to 20 of
your potential voters and supporters
feel so demotivated by the message that
it's been rigged and it's not fair that
it's not just that's interesting but in
Georgia for example in that special
election you know which was the one that
tipped the balance in the Senate I don't
even know if Trump understands what
farage is saying but it's actually a
very good point which is if you keep
telling people it's rigged they'll be
like I'll just stay home you might be
hurting yourself let's see how Trump
responds there were Lumber that perhaps
didn't go out to vote who would have
done because they felt disgusted with
the whole system well they felt the
election was rigged the preceding
election which was the presidential
election and then when they had a vote a
couple of months later
they really did lose their enthusiasm
and frankly rightfully so they've wow so
do you guys think Trump understands like
farage is saying telling them it was
rigged demotivated them if you didn't
tell them that they might have gone out
in January and you might have won those
two seats Trump seems to be saying
that's right they were demotivated by
the election being rigged like they're
kind of talking about two different
things but he seems to be accepting sort
of what farage says but Trump's it's
it's always unclear what Trump
understands they had no the governor of
Georgia did a terrible job like just
terrible having to do with it so he's
doing the thing farage says to
demotivate voters he's actually doing
that thing election integrity and yeah
they felt they uh they were an election
was rigged and stolen and I would say
they didn't have the uh
the enthusiasm to go out and vote and I
understand that so then the follow-up is
well maybe you would have been better
served not to do that one other thing
Mitch McConnell did a terrible job
because this guy's talking about 600
giving during this troubled time giving
and they're talking about two thousand
dollars uh you don't win elections that
way now right or wrong you just don't
win elections that way so Mitch
McConnell was a disaster and I think
that really they did get a lot of votes
but a lot of people were discouraged
there's no question yeah I'm sure of
that so by you right and so it's like
he's agreeing he's like people were very
very discouraged yes what Nigel farage
is saying is you discourage them
sir looking ahead
you know from here
is the message to look back at November
2020 and to condemn and criticize much
of what happened or is the message to
look forward and try and make sure that
that that weakness in the system can't
exist I think it's both I think it has
to be both we have a base in Alabama as
an example at 69 000 people recently
show up wherever I go we get I think I'm
getting bigger crowds now at the rallies
and you know you've been to plenty of it
I have the biggest crowds I've ever had
and I think it has to be both because if
you don't study what took place and do
something about it if possible I think
they're going to do something about it I
don't view that as a foregone conclusion
if you don't look back you really can't
look to the future but I think it's
really a combination of both and very
strong to the future but also it's very
strong looking back people so they're
looking strongly at the future and
they're also looking very strongly at
the past it sounds like looking at that
very strongly exactly well don't want
that to happen again no and voter ID I
mean for example voter ID is very
there's an overwhelming majority and
it's not just Republican voters or
democrat voters who think voter ID makes
sense we've got to have freedom right if
we didn't have the as an example if we
didn't have what happened in 2020 all of
these legislatures and all of these
people that are meeting and passing
voter ID now would have never happened
notice that there's no proof provided
for even a single assertion that has
been presented in the eight and a half
minutes so far so you know looking back
is okay you have to look both ways but
you can't forget about what happened and
if you did you wouldn't have all of the
things that are happening now happen and
there's some very exciting things but
one of them what's he talking when he
said
is he saying exciting things about
changing the 2020 result that's that
can't possibly be what he means right it
doesn't mean there's exciting things
happening to
that he's not still talking about
changing Nova last November 13 months
ago that's not what he's saying is it
it's not even clear
the big things is voter ID and you have
to stop the mail-in voting the mail-in
voting is is just ripe for fraud and
that's what it was well I'm Keen to look
at this conversation one last point
about the past 6th of January which is
something that your opponents gleefully
seized the Palm particularly you know
the social media Giants on the west
coast and everybody else and I know that
you were willfully misquoted in terms of
what you'd said that day because in many
different ways no you were saying go in
peace and I understand that I get that
looking back on the 6th of January was
it a mistake to have had that rally on
that day well you know I didn't have
there was a rally that was there and if
you look it was a massive rally with
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
people I think it was the largest crowd
I've ever spoken before and the real and
I I reverse it the Insurrection took
place on November 3rd that was election
day oh God and before and after that was
to me the Insurrection and the January 6
was a protest right I would have looked
at the crowds there's not some
revisionist history there huh that is
something else
oh thanks to sinser for signing up via
twitch Prime appreciate that I can't
think of any better day than today to
re-up those twitch Prime Subs second
second day of the month also thanks to
Rex moats who just signed up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
Obama
new member number 24 uh very very much
appreciate that
um oh people are saying there's a Dylan
Burns clip about me links aren't allowed
in the chat but if someone can figure
out how to get me that well I'm glad to
look at that if we have time
um let's uh let's continue as nobody
wants to talk about that
I believe it was the biggest and most
people I and I've spoken to very big
crowds I have never spoken in front of a
crowd that size nobody ever talked about
that and nobody ever talks about it
you've been out of office for almost a
year people should be talking about your
crowd in Alabama then unfortunately some
bad things happen but also the other
side had some very bad things happen and
and Ed this I offered 10 000 and
suggested ten thousand National
Guardsmen we want the National Guard to
be there ten thousand or even the
military because I knew the crowd was
going to be massive because that I have
seen no evidence that what he's saying
right now is true I knew the the anger
that took place over the election being
rigged and I understood that I
understood it better than anybody and
Pelosi and these people turned it down
we would have had tremendous security
but they turned and that would have
stopped people going oh that would have
well it would have stopped any problem
absolutely they turned it down also as
you know the so I guess Trump's version
of events is it was antifa and BLM who
did January 6th the real riot and
Insurrection was November 3rd and Trump
actually would have prevented antifa and
BLM from rioting on January 6th I guess
that's the message from Trump the police
I guess they say were not given proper
instructions by Capitol Hill which is
Pelosi they were given some very bad
instructions so if you look at what
happened and go back and really study it
they were so angered and so upset and so
they I mean people crying they were so
angry but now if you lost the election
people don't act that way but they knew
that we won the election no that's why
they were acting that way
because they lost
and they went there but to me the real
Insurrection if you look at it took
place on Election Day no either way
we've got Biden and Harris in office and
they've got plummeting poll ratings and
we've got a border crisis as you quite
rightly said Law and Order
um the black lives matter movement which
is now becoming increasingly I think
political don't you well it's shocking
that it started off you know with pigs
in a blanket right you know that right
you know the expression like bacon and
they were I was about our police our
great police and all of a sudden this
becomes mainstream I don't really think
so and uh antifa bad very bad bad and
there it is antifa is bad Tifa in that
rally they had antifa leading a lot of
people on that day on January and I will
no evidence of that either I mean not
that I need to tell you guys but hey
that uh it's pretty incredible that
nothing happens to them but the other
side this has been going on for many
years
they're not just about racial equality
then well I think they're about politics
but I think they're about a lot of other
things if you go back to their original
founding of what they were saying kill
the police what they're saying is kill
the police and that becomes mainstream
not good no good we've seen specimens of
it of course yeah we've seen Churchill's
statue to face and all of these things
well you saw a Churchill's uh beautiful
bus when the Churchill bust was defaced
it was just like what happened on
January 6th guys being removed from the
White House when I got there I said
send it back they call would you like to
have the bust of Winston Churchill a
great one right yep even you would say
that yeah absolutely and I said I
absolutely want to explain and as you
know President Obama I believe
sent it back he didn't want it
and I said let's bring it back
Joe Biden got rid of it on the first day
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah which is
why of course there's been no
advancement with trade deals and all the
rest I mean why would you do that with
Winston Churchill and you're trying to
get along with your country and you send
it's such a token but such an important
no I had it back for my entire time oh
man I was there I looked he was a very
handsome man he's very brave Man Too
the Biden G7 Biden turns up at the G7
and this was before he let everybody
down in Afghanistan and and which which
leaves us wondering where is America in
the world now I mean we've got big
threats haven't we we've got a lot of
Russian troops on the Ukrainian border
we've got China uh Evermore bellicos in
their statements about Taiwan all right
I mean have we kind of seen enough I
think we get the picture of it we get
the picture of what it's all about and I
have a YouTube clip out about it I don't
know that we need to do the full thing
um
we're ready to move on okay yeah I want
to say thanks to DQ frisky seal and hash
Assad for signing up via twitch Prime
thank you so so so very much we're
standing by for the Christmas tree
lighting ceremony
um yeah okay so as I said I'm willing to
look at whatever Dylan Burns said about
me or my channel but somebody has to
help me figure out how to find it
because I don't know where it is so you
could either you could email it to info
davidpackman.com or just describe how to
find it and then I would be glad to look
at it
also want to say thanks to affects for
the twitch Prime subscription your
number 28 today
um
a few super chats I suddenly miss
hearing from Jimmy from Philly
farage has an interview show on gbn
where he drinks pints of veil in front
of a pub interior rear projection screen
Giga cringe that sounds pretty bad
GB news is such an embarrassment to my
country yeah
David will you celebrate the Day you no
longer have to worry about which mask
you're going to wear on a plane of
course very much so I I I'm looking
forward to that I like how you can
clearly see Trump's platform shoes in
this interview yeah
um yeah it's not untrue not a joke
right not a joke not a joke nope not one
bit
um okay
yeah I just I I don't know how else I
can say is I can't play the Dylan Burns
clip from him talking about having me on
if someone doesn't tell me where to find
it
I'm not sure I know like how else to
explain this Dylan Burns twitch
let's see
it's just like I just don't know where
the clip is
let's see
um
videos
highlights or popular clips
okay there's only one clip under
highlights
popular clips
um
let's look at like I guess the recent
ones
yeah I don't think I'm going to be able
to find it this way
I I'm sorry guys I'm I'm glad to play it
but I just don't know where on Earth it
is
okay all right we're done with it fine
I just
oh man it's I'm willing to work with you
guys but you got to work with me you got
to work with me okay a few voicemails as
we stand by here let's see uh here's
Eric from Mass I'm sure it's a very
coherent voicemail
hey David Eric from uh
Robert F Kennedy Jr uh one of the most
staunch Democrats ever just released a
book The Real uh Anthony Paul Channel
yeah the book is Bonkers
I had dinner with him once perfectly
nice guy but the book is Bonkers
beautiful you uh felchi is a complete
psychopath the stuff he did the dogs
kids math killing a kids covering it up
uh you need to see this stuff uh this
guy LED you astray yeah I just I it's
it's all boring it's all very very
boring
um he's been calling in a lot actually
hey David it's Eric from Mass uh two
things uh pretty important um
your viewers and you will enjoy this
style first thing is
um check out the guardian
uh federal judge
um
says colemanati is not
what they're using and it's already been
debunked
hey David here from Mass uh the first
500 pages of the Pfizer report are out
um Galaxy 11 has it on uh Twitter and
it's quite plain simple it should have
been recalled
well then the first month man he's
really good I wonder if he even works
it's all crazy
thanks to a John B audio and shugs80 for
the twitch Prime Subs really appreciate
that guys uh also welcoming anybody who
wants to grab a membership at
joinpakman.com I will sing your praises
to a fault to a fault and um you can use
the coupon code Obama to get a 68
discount see it there Obama yeah it
works perfectly here is I think Troy
York mad that I think Dr Oz is a quack
let's see what he has to say
hmm
not playing
it's weird
see if we can find it again
uh where was that oh here it is okay
I'm totally angry at your attack on Dr
memma has Oz uh more typical I want uh
communist propaganda
okay
thank you okay
[Music]
Oz is interesting
was utterly unqualified that's my show
playing in the background
goes on for three full minutes which is
really really strange
really strange
um
oh Jimmy from Philly also calling in
about Dr Oz
something seems up with the voicemail
I've got to like refresh it between
voicemail it's strange
so
Jimmy from Philly what
so I'd like to take this time out to uh
thank you for letting me know that Dr
Rogers running for the Senate here in
Pennsylvania right Jimmy because I'm
sure if I hadn't mentioned it you would
have no idea this is now Jimmy will say
that thanks to me Dr Oz got one more
vote it's like right Jimmy would have no
idea Dr Oz is a candidate word not for
me I didn't know thank you for that
advertisement David there it is and you
know you got a lot of balls balls
calling him a liar like do I hear the
yard well Jimmy I mean explain to me how
do you give me evidence that raspberry
ketones do something for your gut health
tell me about how green coffee bean
extract can do whatever stuffing
Lavender in your sheets at night will
cure or whatever and uh Reiki work so
just send me the evidence Jimmy please
fire is it's it's just too much David
that that's real comedy gold there and I
love that commercial for mushroom coffee
peer-reviewed studies really David
really David
guys it's actual coffee with mushroom
powder I'm making no Health claims
man Jimmy's out shot out of a cannon
someone sent me the Tim pool 49 states
compilation let's take a look at that
this seems interesting
well and Biden might be throwaway
candidates they know they're good
I think Colin bi might be throw away
candidates they know they're going to
get steamrolled in the election I really
don't see the Democrats winning this I
think it's fair to say Trump's going to
win re-election I think Trump might have
a massive massive Victory which shocks
the left I think we're looking at a
trump Victory man Trump 2020 Landslide
even with everything going on with covet
I think that's what we can expect I
wouldn't be surprised at all if Trump
had a 49 State Landslide I think
how can even
I think if you just sat an
eight-year-old down
and you showed them election maps of the
last 20 presidential elections
I don't think any one of them would
believe that
the 2020 election could have had either
candidate winning 49 states
like who how how could anyone believe
that we could see a 49 State Landslide
we may be looking at a Mondale Reagan
type scenario where Trump landslides 49
states and we may now my guess I haven't
spoken to Tim for a while
my guess would be if you confronted him
with this he would say it's the voter
fraud that's responsible right like is
that has he been has he been taken to
task for this
how I guess as you would explain it away
by saying voter fraud and stuff like
that I see a a 49 State Landslide maybe
a 50 state land that'd be amazing I
think we might be seeing a 49 State
Landslide I just really think it's it's
more likely that Trump wins 520
electoral votes no amount of melon
ballots will matter if Trump gets 537 or
36 or even 538 every single electoral
vote we all know Joe Biden will lose
like let's be real man as I've stated a
million and one times Donald Trump's
going to win the Republicans why stop at
50. I actually think it's conceivable if
Trump runs in 2024 he'll win 53 States
sweep ladies and gentlemen Joe Biden has
defeated
all right so that's that's pretty solid
I like that man it's like how on Earth
could you think that that is even
remotely plausible
thanks to Bobby voice intin and Dr kill
switch for the twitch Prime
subscriptions very much appreciate guys
ferret queen says you missed my
anniversary Super Chat it's okay no
biggie
um was that today
Orange is the New Black has a clip about
economic Freakonomics and how abortion
helps Society lowers crime Mississippi
is poor and this applies greatly is that
the one ferret that's the only one I'm
seeing today I apologize
David I'm running for county level
office in California I want to get
people excited about getting involved in
local communities I'd love to talk to
you about my campaign yeah we can't
really we we just we don't have the
bandwidth on the show to do hyper local
campaigns
um we just get dozens and dozens of
requests and we're just it's sad but
we're not able to accommodate them
unfortunately
I wish we could I really do but it's not
plausible
thanks blueberry babe for the continued
sub gifts over on Twitch also thanks to
krillov for the twitch Prime
subscription appreciate that as always
all right let's continue just taking a
bit of a tour through
um some of our voicemails
let's see what else we've got here
um
hmm
what a very very strange voicemails I
have to say
hey Pac-Man this is uh Steph from
Wisconsin so I have an interesting story
and I need your advice and I thought I
need a report this to the CDC okay so my
nephew finally got his second vaccine
dose and suddenly he is amazing at math
he has been acing every single math test
possible is this something I need to
report to CDC I would report that what
do you guys think that's Pro if you get
a dose and then you're incredibly good
at math I think that the authorities
should know about that that's it that's
a big big big deal
um looks like yes yeah I would
absolutely report that doesn't sound
normal it doesn't sound normal at all uh
all right very nicely done stuff I
actually I think oh she calls from a
block number I think Steph has had funny
voicemails before I was gonna look him
up but unfortunately I'm unable
unable at this time
um okay let's uh let's let's hear from
Whitney briefly
so uh what I'm not understanding is like
why in the media does it look like
people are saying to like take your
masks off and all this stuff is
you know uh not necessary
and it's like there's people like saying
stuff like You Don't Own Me stuff like
that and it's like
you're in your house you're not able to
go anywhere you're basically I'm
hunkerous man I have no idea what she's
talking about
hey David it's Eric from Mass uh omapron
is an anagram for moronic
is that true
is that actually true oh macron and
moronic are is that actually an anagram
let me say
uh okay
Omicron
m o r o and I oh my God it is that is
actually pretty this is the only
voicemail from Eric from Mass that I've
actually
found moronic not [ __ ] moronic guys he
he is right actually that's crazy you
cannot be this uneducated there's no way
there's no way you can be this
uneducated or you're having your
followers or whatever you want to call
them let down the path of no return I
don't understand it but
since I've called you since I've told
you and you know all this when the death
starts people will consider you
complicit for putting
um putting it out there and forcing
people and make you know with your words
for some people and being forceful about
it and making people feel stupid and all
this and you know it's going to be on
you all these millions of deaths for a
year he's saying my arrest is imminent
it's crazy
vaccine and this booster [ __ ] and this
garbage I mean are you [ __ ] kidding
me what
I don't know I I'm thinking I think you
need some psychiatric help yeah
well just to be clear because YouTube is
getting very strict the assertions made
by Eric from Massachusetts are not
backed by science uh millions of people
have not died from the vaccines
uh but Omicron is an anagram for moronic
that is true and I I that I I concede to
I will stipulate to that
um another one from Whitney
virginity
love but I don't see how they would be
able to have the kind of technology to
trace the origins
to the per space location well you don't
have to understand it Whitney there's
many Technologies I don't understand but
I believe they exist
[Music]
um
yeah
hi David so last Sunday I actually fell
down some steps and busted my ass
outside my apartment and had to go to
the local hospital Dad I'm sorry to hear
I got to see firsthand uh just the crazy
epidemic that the nurses are having to
deal with we could hear them out in the
hallway talking about how overworked
they were and there were people before
me that had been waiting 20 hours and
still had not gotten a room so the
struggle is real even though a lot of
people try to deny it and this was a
major State Hospital don't worry
nothing's broken and I'm doing better
Happy Thanksgiving that's good to hear
wow that's that's man that's really
something hey David it's Sarah from Mass
um I got a question for you
um maybe you can answer me uh where is
the line for you on the vaccines the
line all right
you know follow me here you've had my by
my account if you count if you're
scoring at home like they say on games
uh you've taken four you've taken the
original two you've just took your
booster and you're gonna take the flu
one
okay so that's four and wait hold on if
so if the question is how many vaccines
have I had in my life it's I don't know
how that's relevant to covet I mean in
my life how many what what are the
vaccines I've had in my life
uh tetanus a few a few times
um MMR
I've had what 20 flu vaccines
um Hep B is a common one I mean it's
probably a couple dozen and what kind of
a question is that what would the what's
the end game the end game is avoiding
diseases for which we have vaccines
that's my end game
nine I don't know 11 months depending
where you got at 9 10 11 months and my
question is about you is out there
saying for a year what's your line for a
year what is he talking about
um is that fine every three months how
about every two months how about every
one month
how about every week
what's your line where you finally say
something's not right here
because mine was at zero
but that's me all right well don't get
any vaccines and uh also by the way I
hope that Eric also doesn't take
antibiotics
um I I like I hope he actually really
is principled in this you know
uh refuse any treatments not available
before 1880
um use leeches I mean you know really
really Go With It Go Go with the full
thing
hey David it's Eric from last again I
almost forgot uh looks like uh evidence
is out and the people who got that new
variant are all been fully vaccinated so
basically yeah so that's not true it's a
mix and you know this was from Saturday
24 of 12 hours after we learned about it
uh pretty sad actually that that people
people believe this stuff it's extremely
extremely weaponized stuff
um yeah also I mean I hope he's not
using Vision any kind of uh artificial
vision correction that's not natural I
mean contact lenses and glasses very
very much not natural that is not
something uh you know if God intended
for us to be able to see well we would
have uh we wouldn't need glasses and
contacts
um he should stop using his Viagra
prescription that's very much not
natural that that should be stopped uh
uh shouldn't use I mean antibacterial
soap that is straight up uh that is
devilish that is devilish actually I
don't use antibacterial so I read that
it may kill good bacteria I don't know
about that I just use regular soap he
should use untreated tap water certainly
shouldn't be calling me on an iPhone
okay and and I ca he shouldn't be Dr if
he's driving a car we're really going to
have a problem with this guy
um
hey by the way you know at this point
I've bought will you guys believe I've
bought hundreds of pairs of contact
lenses it's like what is the limit right
they sell you one pair and that's not
even the end you gotta buy another pair
and another pair and another pair it
must be a scam just on that basis
all right uh very sad guy very very sad
guy kind of seems like a Jimmy from
Philly type character where his life is
probably sad in some in some way
uh okay guys that's gonna do it for me
today they're running an hour late on
this Christmas thing and I'm Jewish
anyway so my my why am I watching a
Christmas tree lighting we covered
everything I wanted to cover we've done
it all we really have done it all so the
best to everyone I am going to be
bringing you some really interesting
things over the next few weeks of travel
I'll tell you more about it at my first
opportunity see everybody very soon